and many many other chemicals that are
known to have the impact of of endocrine
disruption they disrupt in mammals and
other
animals normal sexual development so
that that is non-controversial nobody
disagrees with that on the the the study
that I referred to and any of you can
look this up on your cell phones right
now on
Google is a study in which a scientist
uh and I I I can't remember his last
name I know his first name is Tyler um
but you can look it up and you can use
the first name but you don't even need
to do that you just put arrine and
sexual dimorphism or sexual changes in
frogs and that's going to come up on
your Google you're going to see a
peer-reviewed published study